welcome back to Pittsburgh
associating major Buzz online with a
contrarian view she's appeared in a
couple of debates on this show it's
called uncensored after all we welcome
any honestly held opinions but this week
she's facing a major backlash of posting
a song titled why can't we talk about
the Jews which is dedicated to far-right
commentator Nick Fuentes we've all later
deleting it
why can't we talk about the
without getting kicked off of you too
now I'm not saying Hitler was a good guy
[Music]
but I kind of Wanna Know
why
now there's all these conspiracy
theories
and the more they talk I think maybe
they're right
but I can't even listen to the convo
well Paul joins me now along with the
New York author and founder of Ender Jew
hatred Brook Goldstein over in the
states all right Paul
you've come on the show a couple of
times right we've had some spirited
debates about feminism and stuff like
that and I thought you've made some good
points and it's got lots of traction
then I wake up the other day and I see
this thing that's trending involving you
doing this song
and I couldn't really believe what I was
watching I didn't know why why are you
very funny
huh did you find it funny I mean you
know the backlash today I mean you you
deleted it you obviously thought you
shouldn't have posted it why did you do
that
genuine question I mean the point was
more about cancel culture and people
getting kicked off of social media if
you finish the song it was more about
like you can't talk about this topic
without being canceled by the left and
the right I don't really have a strong
opinion either way it was kind of just
like tongue-in-cheek
um I didn't really expect it to get that
crazy
um I also it wasn't dedicated to anyone
I don't know why they say that but
that's not true I mean Nick Fuentes is a
white supremacist he's a holocaust
denier uh he said afterwards that you
had dropped a diss track on the Jews
um which he clearly took to be something
which was you know mocking Jewish people
talking about I'm not saying Hitler was
a good guy but I want to know why what
do you want to know why well it was more
like why can't we talk about it it
wasn't like we talked about the more
conspiracy theories you've heard about
Hitler and the Holocaust Museum I'm a
fan of conspiracy theory like you know
people think I'm part of the CIA there's
a whole conspiracy thing online and you
know I'm not for like silencing it
either way the point of the song isn't
like I really have an opinion on the
matter it's more
I don't think we should ban people off
of social media so far so that I don't
even like I think it should be illegal
to ban anybody off of social media
unless they are inciting violence that
was the point of the song I'm not really
it was more like tongue but just to be
clear what are the conspiracy theories
surrounding Hitler which you feel I
don't know you hear them the more you're
interested in them well I don't know
because I can't hear them
well you know the ones you know the ones
that Nick fuented well I wasn't even
talking about Nick I was thinking of yay
to be honest I don't know why they put
that Nick was the inspiration for that
song I was thinking of yay you are aware
of the big backlash disease and the Deep
upset from Jewish Community I certainly
am now I just posted that song and I
woke up and I was like article article
article I was like golly right but are
you sorry crazy
um you know I I think that
um
like what it my whole point was that
cancel culture is wrong I am not
speaking one way or the other about the
issues my question is why are we
canceled about talk for talking about
certain topics so you would allow
Holocaust deniers to have space on
social media to promote Holocaust denial
to millions of people you have two
million people who subscribe to your
YouTube right that's a big audience of
people I'm not at 2 million yet I'd like
to be right but you have a lot of people
that follow you on the various social
media platform yeah you put a video like
that up and there are going to be some
impressional young ones going hang on
what's Pearl saying Adolf Hitler not
saying he's a good guy but I want to
know why the more conspiracies I I
theories I hear the more I have to think
about it but I took that to me I took
that to mean that you agree with me
why did you cut off the end of the end
of the song I said but we can't even
have the conversation what is the
conversation you want without being
canceled before the left and the right
what is the conversation about Hitler
and conspiracy theories and the
Holocaust that you want to have I
any conversation my Lane is feminism
that's what you're singing about adults
you do want to have that conversation I
want anybody that wants to speak on
social media to be able to speak about
what they want to talk about getting
banned whatever they want to talk about
during Holocaust denial if they want to
talk about that as long as they're not
inciting violence I think people also
inciting Vines
Jewish people so short look at social
media is the New Town Square right you
used to be able to go and say your
opinions in the Town Square now we have
corporations censoring what can and
cannot be said and I think that's wrong
I think that should be illegal let me
bring in Brooke good he's been listening
to this Brooke I don't think Paul quite
understands why the wording of this song
which she deleted to be clear so
obviously realized this is not played
out maybe the way she hoped
um the offense is caused to the Jewish
Community why was it so offensive
well first of all I want to thank you uh
for having me on and for highlighting
this issue not necessarily highlighting
Pearl but highlighting the issue that
what you pointed out is that we're
really facing a crisis of societal
conscious where someone like Pearl who
engages in hate speech and actually the
irony issues complaining about being
canceled and that she's on your platform
she has millions of viewers on the
internet and on social media and she's
complaining about being canceled the
crisis is that this is what is
profitable now this click bait this type
of racial incitement is profitable on
the internet and you know I'm sitting
here I'm listening to Pearl I I don't
know if she's just plain stupid or she's
actually quite intelligent and knows
that what she's doing is so Sensational
that is going to make her a lot of money
but I want to say one thing Pearl will
disappear she will disappear like many
others before her because this is
something that's just a moment in time
she's like a train wreck it's like a car
crash you know for example you can't you
know you shouldn't be looking at it but
you can't take your eyes off it but I
want to make one more point I think it's
so important especially on this platform
hatred is taught nobody is born like
this and I talk about it a lot in my
book about the dangers of hate education
and it's not something that we can
debate that we can engage in a rational
argument with you can see what her
opinions are she thinks women shouldn't
vote women shouldn't have the right to
divorce she thinks that women should be
able to work she says these no I didn't
say crazy things
Hitler but they're putting rational
please don't interrupt there's no
rational argument with someone like this
and this is a mistake that my community
makes the Jewish Community very often
that they think they can bring facts to
the table that they can debate somebody
like Pearl and it's you know you're
gonna get there you're not gonna get any
work you're going to get Somewhere Only
by shedding the light on this type of
bigotry to expose
I would let me just offer you some
advice right because I don't think
you're stupid and in the two appearances
you've made previously on this program I
thought it was it was interesting it was
controversial in some ways but actually
a lot of people would have agreed with
some of the things he was saying there's
no question about that but you seem to
know where the line was someone like
Nick Fuentes doesn't know where the line
is someone like Kanye West who I
interviewed after he went on some weird
anti-semitic Trope nonsense chutney's
been wiped out by what he did well what
he said about the Jewish people because
there are certain things where I am
absolutely in support of the concept of
free speech right but you can't go
around telling Jewish people the
Holocaust didn't happen as the winters
and people like Fuentes does say things
like that but I'm not I'm not him
sing me a song right and you talk about
who determines what the line is Pierce
well who determines
I'm asking you who gets to determine you
to work out in your head I'm saying that
you're not a stupid person when you say
I'm not saying Hitler was a good guy but
I want to know why right when you talk
about the more conspiracy theories about
in my hair the more I'm like well that's
interesting I'm just like a Gog that
even now you don't seem to really grasp
why singing that and releasing it to
millions of people is incredibly
offensive to Jewish people foreign
I think at the end of the day at the end
of the day Pierce I don't think it's for
you to determine what speech should be
allowed what about you determine why did
you delete it why did I delete it
because it was just a headache Fierce
because you knew it was wrong it's it's
I just think it's it's like
it's not the hill I'm trying to die on
right but why did you choose that hill
to dial I didn't choose this hill to die
dude you released That You released the
video I also released 10 different
videos
but they're not talking about Adolf
Hitler are they are we not allowed to
talk about him you could talk about
hitting the right to the point you say
the more conspiracy there is a hear
about him look at I think that anyone
should be allowed to speak about any
conspiracy theory on social media that
is my point it's not about Hitler it's
not if you really believe what you did
wasn't wrong you wouldn't have deleted
it oh wow okay don't you think I I agree
with pearl
go on Brooke
if I may just say one one thing as an
attorney I have to say that I I do agree
with her that I am a free speech purist
and I think that even bigotry should uh
be able to be spoken in in the public
sphere but the problem of canceled
culture is not against
anti-jewish speech I think that's very
clear we see the scourge of
anti-Semitism and Jew hatred Rising on
the internet the problem is that there's
no consequences for it and the way that
private are there no consequences
canceling is they're going after
pro-jewish speech they're going after
pro-israel speech I can't tell you how
many times I'm contacted by people and
often my own clients who are shut down
on social media for saying anything
positive about Jewish people about
Judaism or about Israel yet these social
media companies are unequally applying
their own standards and you know while
they're for example shutting down covid
deniers they are allowing Holocaust
denial speech they are allowing people
like Pearl to spew her hatred so if we
are really free speech purists and
that's what we are are you saying that
companies they should allow all speakers
yeah I hear listen I I would just say
this to you unless it's incitement to
immediate violence right I would say
this Depot so we agree well I would say
this to you in conclusion on the same
team now thank you all in conclusion
look you deleted this so you clearly
felt bad about what you'd put up or you
wouldn't have deleted it you accept that
no you don't accept it I just you know
it's kind of a headache I was like well
it just seems like a lot of headache to
me right or did you realize actually in
that moment from the visceral reaction
from the Jewish Community you crossed a
line a line that you yourself should
have worked out was there look at the
end of the day pierce the song was about
freedom of speech it wasn't one way or
the other the song was about why can't
we have these conversations on social
media and why do I keep getting maybe a
good guy why do I keep seeing people get
banned on social media my point is I I
don't think there should be a line
unless you're inciting violence
would we agree on that yes or no no yes
or no do you agree he's my no no you
haven't answered my question okay I'm
not saying Hitler was a good guy but I
want to know why I want to know why what
we can't have the conversation without
being canceled by the left and the right
I just don't understand the conversation
you guys cut out wait a minute oh you
did 30. okay the conversation about
whether Hitler was a good guy you want
to have that conversation I think that
he might have 12 million people getting
six million dollars look at my it my
whole point is we should be able to have
that conversation but whether he's a
good guy yes because it causes more
commotion when you're starting to censor
people I don't know I think that's wrong
to censor anybody well you know what you
can have that conversation you had that
conversation you posted it you haven't
been canceled I've had you on the show
because I thought you might with time to
think about this regret what you did
because you can clearly you're not
stupid you do understand the offense it
caused and wanting to have the right to
debate whether Hitler's a good guy is
just crazy no no I want anybody to be
able to speak on any platform that was
the point of the song
all right let's leave it can I point out
a Nuance here I've got a book I'm sorry
we want to run out of time but thank you
for coming on the program I greatly
appreciate it and Paul uh thank you for
coming on I appreciate it